[Music]
we use a lot of ID therapy to treat
hangovers if you use the right vitamins
there won't be any side effects success
rate using IV therapy is over 75 percent
in our practice I can't really remember
the last time I've been super hung over
I really do hope that IV therapy works
and works well maybe I'll go through
this and go wow this is life-changing if
this works it's kind of scary in a way
because now there's like no consequences
for drinking no consequences for
drinking all right guys great bottoms up
that's pretty smooth oh yeah let's just
start with two let's just kick it off
better get it over with right away Oh
wasn't as good I'm up to here in the SAS
meter we're taking a nosedive here very
quickly I just go would just go isn't
take another shot and just wait till we
meet up amazing she was supposed to meet
up with this I don't know where she is
right now
just finished beard number one beautiful
beautiful boy it's a mistake shot you
could stop
my
nobody all right right now we're getting
pulled over by the cops oh my god we
actually are best friends forever never
Riley at the bar they see you scoundrel
this is mine
[Music]
we mix so many Outlaws loser has so many
sweet dreams
tomorrow Oh God
okay look these Hawks just killed this
bird I don't care if I wish they would
kill me
I'm actually really afraid of needles
but I just want to feel better so just
stick it in me doc so who wants it all
first Ryan I think yeah all right all
right let's get over with chuckles
making that same face okay I want you
happen
not too bad right I'm a little bit
nervous when I woke up this morning I
felt like dying
Jen it's okay in Wednesday's am i right
or is it Tuesday Wednesday Ryan and it
goes you didn't even flinch I'm excited
because I don't feel good and I want
this to work like as fast as possible
oh I can taste the vitamin already I'm
having a great time with you guys bring
our bag over to brunch when was the last
time any of you were that drunk last
weekend how where where does all this
liquid go are we are we filling up like
balloons right now I'm gonna take a an
IV bag selfie everybody turn around
[Music]
excuse me I have places to be you see
you suckers at the water cooler
oh Jesus stepping away from the
situation well I'm almost done Paul and
there's a bump right there look out
there's a bomb
just another thing that don't act like
even see weird things Ned you've got
people I think he's got twisted
I totally twist IV bags do you any day
this is gonna be us in sixty years right
except it'll be like you know or this
could just be the way the future oh my
god oh Jesus what have you done
Jen your blood your precious blood what
did you do Jen all that for a banana I
think the most concerning thing is that
my big takeaway from this was like
drinking on a Tuesday can we as humanity
handle business I do feel like I'm
starting to feel better but I don't know
if it's just in my head
we're dead I didn't think it would work
as well as it did I still feel pretty
hungover right now I think it certainly
worked it's just that I'm not sure if it
would be worth it for me
other people Ryan maybe it might be
worth it for Ryan to do this all the
time
I was on my deathbed this morning and I
a hundred percent feel better right now
but uh me nah I'm good my dad why would
we FaceTime your dad ever I don't know
he's a nice my dad's really a writer
I'm gonna listen to my parents to see